hey everyone for those of you who don't
know me my name is Eddie whoo and I'm a
mathematics teacher in Sydney Australia
for the last seven years I've uploaded
videos of my classroom teaching to
YouTube and if you watch any of those
videos one things you'll notice is that
I use a piece of graphing software
called desmos with my students all the
time we use it to help us visualize and
explore different functions and other
kinds of mathematical phenomena and
because I use desmos virtually every day
I was super excited when the team of
desmos reached out to me and asked if I
would help to judge the first-ever
desmos global mathematics art
competition since from all over the
world have created artworks using
nothing more than equations in desmos
and I've been asked to pick out some of
my favorites from the fifteen or sixteen
and seventeen to eighteen age category
so gonna show some of them to you right
now this first one here is from kashira
wada now human mind
it's famously poor at creating
randomness and you know there's a
fantastic arrangement of Sakura flowers
in this artwork and I can see there's a
wonderful balance between chaos and
structure and I particularly love the
care that was taken in creating the
branches so they mimic the fractal
geometry of real trees so very very
impressive work this next one here is
from Grace Kelly and I just think
there's this ingenious use of elliptical
arcs and trigonometric functions to
create the the wavy hair and the snake
bodies as well and I think the thing I
especially love about this one
is that the technical brilliance that
grace is used it's so seamless that it
allows us the viewer to be taken in by
the emotion on the characters face even
though this makes themselves like some
of them have real attitude okay let's
have a look at the next one this is from
Alex and Manville mooch and you know
artists and art critics they've pondered
the starry night for well over a century
and with good reason
its depiction of mathematical turbulence
in the sky it's kind of entrancing if
you just kind of stand there and
for a long time and this artwork has
really cleverly used color and Bezier
curves to create a stunning effect a
great job Alex and then my last one that
I wanted to highlight in this age
category was from YY and this is kind of
like a meta desmos face like a desmos
piece about desmos it's a wonderful
reflection of the fact that I think
desmos itself is a piece of art that's
been crafted with great skill and care
by the team of people who put it
together so nicely done all right let's
go over to the 17 to 18 age category so
this one's from jerod Giorgio and
Etienne now I think this is you know
amazing to me this one because it takes
real courage to tackle the complexities
and nuances of a human face with nothing
but circles and parabolas and this is a
self-portrait that it even makes things
harder by adopting a very extreme
perspective that removes some of the
natural symmetries which would have made
this task simpler and and pulls it off
with some impressive style okay this
next one here is by Kaitlin minute Euler
Minitel oh sorry
now the design of this kissy Cathedral
it's marked by an almost feverish level
of discipline and level of detail and
when you combine that with this very
subtle animation in there I think it's
an effort that the the real architects
were very very proud of okay this one's
from Ava citta now in mathematics in
general we prize simplicity in our
proofs and this piece takes that
principle and then it embodies it
artistically the choice of functions
here is relatively understated but the
overall effect is really striking and I
particularly like the decision to mirror
a classic view of an iconic object
that's something it's very very clever
this last one here from Judy in Malaysia
this artwork I think it employs one of
the best uses of vanishing lines and
relative size to provide a genuine
foreground and background the fact that
it also depicts what we mathematics
teachers love to work toward you and
an engaged group of students it's also a
very nice touch so I want to say I've
been congratulations to all of the
people who are finalists thank you to
everyone who submitted something I
really enjoyed having you look at all of
the entries and enjoy exploring the
artistic and creative aspects and the
technical skill that's required to use
desmos in this ways great job everyone